okay we got the Monday night crowd
tonight
looks like there's not a lot of people
here we got Danny Machuca we got Ben
Simon and that's all you need we're
doing it tonight and it's been a very
strange night a bit of a late start but
we're doing it this is it we're doing it
it's a very special night for those
people that are managed to make it out
here tonight because it's the start of a
brand new tournament called Monday night
mayhem so right after the lecture
whatever opening I pick will be a
thematic tournament based around that
opening and you'll play one game every
Monday night so if you're in the area
you might want to come out it's a real
cool tournament you play one game every
Monday you don't know what the opening
is going to be till you show up at class
and all right so it should be just a lot
of fun something new every week and the
winner this month I will receive a free
entry to the Metro class championship
which is on February 6th that's a $50
value and the winner of each section of
each class will get 200 bucks so that
should be a fun one and okay you can win
free entry you won't have to pay
anything to get in um all right so uh
you know there was a lot of lot of
possible entries for tonight and it was
hard to decide I mean there's so many
good ones we're about to start a
tournament what should I do
I couldn't figure it out so I had to use
some technology to help me now
unfortunately my rug 4-thousand crashed
and I had tried to reboot it but it
didn't work and I crashed I mean it fell
down several flights of stairs and by
reboot I mean I kicked it repeatedly
with a boot and now it broke but the
club assured me don't worry we'll get
you the brand new one so with great
pleasure I get to introduce to you the
wrong 5,000 3s all right here it is
the wrong 5000 the newest in best in
opening generating technology as you'll
notice there are several tubes at the
top it says here sharp for the sharp
openings solid welcome Mario Roper for
the solid openings and we did some
suspicious openings but our current
resident Grand Master threatened to sue
us so we changed the final s to suspect
openings so we'll get to those at the
very end so let's put some of these
openings in here and we'll see what we
have we get tonight so all right we got
some sharp openings we got the elven
counter gambit people have been dying to
see it we got some Sicilian Knight
Orff's in here some Grune felled some
Kings Indian what else we got we got a
lot of good stuff so let's see we got a
six of them here all right and let's
just go ahead and pour them into the
special tube here excellent down they go
excellent they're in there they're in
the system and obviously there's some
very complex tubes and an integrated
system within the box so if you thought
the outside was impressive you should
see what's on the inside so now we move
on to the solid openings in here we got
the Rui Lopez we got the Queens gambit
accepted and a very controversial one
for us here at the club
the Scandinavian some people have said
like somebody in our audience tonight
the Scandinavian is a suspicious opening
but I've decided to classify it as a
solid opening yes you move your queen a
little bit you're shaking your head but
you get a very solid position you know
you get your pawns on e6 and c6 solid as
a rock all right and now we move on to
our suspect openings these openings are
truly atrocious I mean they're just
really bad so without further ado let's
put these guys in here in here we got
the Grob all right we got just four
danny Machuca
we got the wandering King and what else
we got in there and another one that's
just bad all right so now let's give
this a good shake here all right this is
it we're only doing it once not goofing
around if I could find one all right
excellent got one perfect
whatever we got here this is what we're
doing tonight let's just take a quick
look all right what do we got what do we
got excellent we pick a nice sharp one
tonight so that's pretty exciting
tonight we got a the ki D the Kings
Indian defense so excellent wonderful
let's do it um all right and we'll enter
serious mode now yeah I have this kind
of apathetic towards this one it's I
know a little bit so it should be fine
it should be a fun one tonight the Kings
Indian defense will just get ready to it
will check out the board now okay so
yeah White has seized some space on the
Queen side and you know in most openings
White is trying to play the moves
efore and d4 here white intends you know
just get his night out and to play e4
and unlike many openings in the Kings
Indian defense black doesn't prevent him
he lets white get this Center and then
they counter-strike later on so we'll
put the main move on here Knight c3
white simply intends to play e4 get a
big center and in the Kings Indian
defense black just allows them to do it
but tonight we'll look at the Kings
Indian and white gets to play a really
big center so he's pretty happy and now
the main move is d6 to prevent white
from ever kicking the night away with E
5 Bobby Fischer used to Castle here on
occasion which is an interesting
variation and normally white doesn't
advance
he'll just play some normal move like
develop is night if you advance the
knight will retreat to a silly square
but black intends to attack the white
center so that's an interesting option
if you you want to check it out it is
possible to castle
here but alright d6 that's the main move
and that's what we're going to look at
tonight now lots of people were
requesting the Seamus the sandwich
variation but tonight we're going to
focus on the main line because I think
that's what most people are here to see
and it's only fair that for the
tournament tonight we play some you know
normal book position all right from here
okay let's let's castle and now white
will normally develop his bishop and
that you should follow my rule here h3
is also a possible move here but should
he go to e2 or d3 well I tell my
students you don't want to put your
Bishop on d3 when your opponent has
fianchettoed and they have a pawn on g6
it's kind of like your bishop is aimed
at a wall and you're never going to
sacrifice there if you're going to
sacrifice and take on g6 then you know
that's pretty good move you should have
your bishop here but in general when
they have this formation the bishop
belongs on e to where yes there's a
knight in the way but it will prevent
black from ever bringing his knight out
somewhere in the future so yeah
occasionally he's going to try to read
maneuver his night and you okay you'll
be ready to stop him all right so the
main move here Bishop e2 main move is be
5 so that's what we're going to check
out and the most common move is to
castle so well that's what we're going
to look at tonight if you've never seen
this position before
you might be thinking as white you can
just go ahead and grab a pond here a
Jacob Wilkin specialty the exchange
variation so black will take back now
the D file is open so when the D file is
open you have to choose if you want to
trade Queens or not and let's suppose
white wants to trade and he decides I'm
going to grab this pawn what does black
play here Knight takes e4 yeah never
forget about this bishop he's a very
powerful piece in this opening there's
always tricks on this diagonal so ok so
that would be a way to lose upon instead
if you do play this variation normally
you
Sol and then okay and then you can you
continue from here normally black
protects the pond and this night jumps
in and you know you get some some
position it's not thought to be the a
great way for white to get an advantage
so we'll we'll skip it for now
d5 also is normal enough I mean seems to
make sense right you get a lot of space
and the plan here for black is to bring
his knight to the c5 square really nice
square and he played the move a5 so that
it's really difficult to ever kick this
night away you know you'd have to
prepare it and the knight gets to stay
there with lots of pressure in the
center so also an interesting variation
but uh for times sake we are starting a
little bit late tonight so we're just
going to get right to the good stuff
we castle and okay I mean there's other
moves for black here other than the main
move he can take he can you know even
like ninety six is a move but let's get
right to business here Knight to c6
forcing white to you know play d5 he's
trying to provoke it and now we get an
interesting position and we'll start to
see the plans here in just a minute
White's plan is to play on the Queen
side you'll notice he has more space
here his pawns are pointing this way
you'll notice black has more space on
the Kings side so black is going to be
playing for a King side attack he's
going to be playing moves like f5f for
g5 and he's going to go try to attack on
the King side white meanwhile is going
to be getting an advantage on the Queen
side he's trying to play the move c5 and
there's several ways to do it he can
prepare with b4 he can prepare it by
having some pieces in play to control
the move c5 and he's going to try to
break through on the on the Queen side
and this is one of the sharpest openings
black is going all out for an attack so
usually either black checkmates white or
white defense properly wins on the Queen
side and will ultimately win the game
because blacks you know Queen side is
usually just torn to shreds he just
gives up on it for an all-out attack and
so you get a very sharp opening so
that's why we we had it in the sharp
category we'll go one move further here
eighty-one is the main move so we'll
check that out tonight and all right so
we'll jump into it from here we'll get
some games to be fair for our tournament
we'll get a game where white wins a game
where black wins so we'll just jump here
on the database search for this position
okay so this is a game that I actually
know because it was played right here in
st. Louis this was a this year last year
2015 at the Sinquefield Cup so I
actually do know a little bit about this
game so that's kind of exciting man this
was a fantastic game so we're going to
look at it this was the game between
Wesley so with white versus Hikaru
Nakamura as black and I taught this to
one student you know that was back in
like August September so hopefully I
still know a little bit but this is a
fantastic game so this is all right I'm
glad this was like the top one this is
that this is a great game ok so I just
played the move Knight to e1 alright and
now what black wants to do is he wants
to begin to attack on the King side so
he's got to get this Knight out of the
way one of the benefits from Knight to
e1 is right as we've said before now
we've prevented moves like Knight to h5
because we could just take it so he's
going to have to go back either to D
seven or eight in the game D seven was
chosen it's nice to have a night that
controls the c5 break at least for the
moment it's not so bad that we block in
this Bishop normally this is one of
Black's last pieces that he's going to
develop and often the key sacrifice is
going to be taking on h3 when your
opponent plays Bishop takes h3 that
usually means you're lost they're
sacrificing and that's they open up your
Kings side and they win so it's a very
common sacrifice that both players
should know about you know he's trying
to sacrifice his bishop if whatever ends
up putting a pawn on h3
okay so what's white doing alright he's
maneuvering his knight to d3 okay but in
this game he chose a the f3 line which
is also interesting the point is now
he's going to put his bishop and he can
put it all the way back on f2 when black
he anticipates the blacks going to play
a 5
the Bishop's going to go back to f2 and
he'll be nice and safe and having more
pieces around his King is going to be
nice because black is going for a big
attack here so white will have some
pieces with which to defend and okay if
they Knight if the bishop does end up on
f2 it does put them on a really nice
diagonal here where it can work as a
defender and it can go to work on the
Queen side okay f5 as as expected so
this is White's last chance to play
Bishop e3 before black plays f4 all
right and f4 and the bishop drops back
excellent so far so far I remember this
game alright and yeah black is he's
coming he's going to keep moving these
ponds up maybe the Knights going to go
to g6 and for white yeah we're going to
bring a knight to d3 and we're going to
play for c5 so these moves happened and
I just show this to a student and he was
you know getting kind of worried why
would white play like this blacks attack
is coming so fast and yeah it does kind
of look like that so how is white going
to generate enough pressure on the Queen
side and okay let's think about this
night for a second well yeah we're ready
to play a move like c5 now
and sometimes this Knight will even jump
back to f2 where it guards the critical
g4 square because that's one of the key
breaks the black is playing for now so
let's see what happened here all right
Knight to g6 getting more attackers over
there he's going to eventually play for
these breaks he might end up putting you
know more of his Knights back here so
what is white gonna do he's ready to
play c5 so c5 was played immediately
alright so what is what is black gonna
do here perhaps he'll get this Knight
out of the way alright and there's
there's a couple plans for white
normally he's going to try to create a
weakness on the Queen side he's going to
at some point take on d6 to get this
this pawn isolated here and then he'll
be able to attack d6 with moves like
Knight to b5
he can bring his rooks over he's going
to try to get into the key c7 square so
we're going to see that so he puts his
rook here immediately and that white is
ready let's just make a bad move for
black here just for a second
white is now ready to take and play the
move Knight to c5 which is threatening
to come into c7 which is usually trouble
for black and even if that Knight does
get expelled
often the knight will come to e6 even
allowing this trade which is perfectly
normal because that's one of the key
defender or key attackers for black that
LightSquared bishop so a night on e six
is fine even if you're upon this week
this is a King's Indian so people are
going to sacrifice lots of material also
there's a threat here on a7 so notice we
our Bishop is doing a nice job so he
would have to worry about that and often
allowing that pawn to be taken is a part
of black strategy you know you can say
white go ahead spend the time take my
pawn on a seven meanwhile I'm going to
get my attack rolling over here so
that's very interesting so let's see so
King h8 doesn't make a lot of sense but
rook f7 does preemptively you know
preventing stuff for having on the c7
square and if necessary black often
drops his knight back to e8 just really
keeping control over the c7 square
that's why it's big entry point and so
black is trying to already stop them he
understands what White's trying to do
and alright so an interesting move King
h1 and if I remember right Wesley played
a lot of moves really quickly like this
was all his prep but he didn't end up
getting a good position in this game so
all right but okay he makes room the
bishop might drop back to g1 all right
so what is black going to do here all
right h5 the attack continues and yes my
student was really worried here you know
it's like wow a back is attacking really
fast
here comes g4 g3 here comes H 4 H 3 is
some sort of break here that will rip
open the position
so white decides alright now I get some
counterplay here and an interesting move
Knight to b5 often white will play the
move a4 to prevent what happened in the
game so a possible way they white could
have improved maybe was to play a4 with
a different idea the point is once your
Knight ends up on b5 black won't be able
to expel it with a 6 and a quick b5
which we'll see in the game so will see
what I'm talking about
he went for Knight b5 immediately so
black has c7 under control but is white
thinking of about taking upon it could
be you know that could be one of his his
plans here so black has to decide do I
let my a pawn fall do I just you know go
in for the attack well hákarl here chose
to kick out the night and okay so the
knight has to go back but wensley's
happy he did what he was trying to do he
weakened some dark squares around here
so he's hoping to reorganize his Knight
so he can get into these squares and if
I remember right he went to a3 so we'll
look at that in a second I'm Knight to
c3 is not such a silly retreat we did
get some weaknesses to work with here so
if we just lets waste waste a move for
black not a good move at all but I move
like Knight a 4 and we got 2 pieces
coming in here to b6 and so that's what
we was hoping for he's trying to create
some weaknesses here so this was
possible in the game he chose Knight to
a3 with a similar idea because now you
can play Knight to c4 and get one of
these pieces in to some of these dark
squares so should you a car we'll play
the move b5 and stop that idea well he
chose that now if white already had upon
on a for black wouldn't be able to
choose this option so in this position
with the pawn on a4 White's position
would be a little bit better than it was
in the game but I think this is what
Wesley was hoping for because now not
only are some of these dark squares weak
you got some light squares over here
particularly c6 so now White has an
entrance he's going to be able to put a
piece on c6 and there's a couple
contenders the rook seems to make the
most
because it's attacking everything at
some point though maybe okay and I can
jump in there now he's got some
something to work with on the queenside
but he's got to prove that he can do
something over there before black
crushes them and mates them on the
kingside so let's see the rook jumps
into c6 all right which makes sense but
we'll see later
I remember if I remember right I think I
do he's going to make a mistake with
that that rook so let's see what should
what should black do let's see all right
g4 get on with the attack and okay in
the typical plan now is just to play it
moves like h4 h3 really force something
to open up over there on the Kings side
let's see what was Wesley's move I think
keeping in see should probably begin to
triple on the C file yes that's what
happened and then black shows something
very interesting he kind of wants to
kick this rook away even though the rook
may or may not have to actually leave we
can think about sacrificing in exchange
but obviously if he plays here
immediately
he's dropping his deep on and then once
that falls I mean the whole Queen side
is going to fall apart so if I if I
remember right cooing to f8 which is
interesting normally the bishop goes to
f8 so I didn't know about this plan
during the game but black was thinking
okay so he protected it with his queen
which is you know not the most common
but it worked really well in this game
and one of the nice assets of having the
Queen on f8 is he plays the move Bishop
to h6 and with the bishop on h6 he can
think about some typical Knight
sacrifices this Knight here is often key
to to sacrificing on this pawn chain and
you can imagine ok sacrificing for this
pawn makes sense if you know White has
to take back and you get to move here
and the bishop gets out and he gets
loose so sometimes that can be a crusher
you know the bishop gets to a really
great good angle and sometimes he can
sacrifice on e4 knowing that okay
to move f3 and really quickly and one of
those sacrifices happened in the game so
when we get to it we'll we'll see it
ok so white triples and alright now he
gets to kick the rook away and so this
is kind of where my knowledge of this
game runs out I know that white made a
mistake here he does not have to move
his rook and all of the commentators
both the live commentators down in the
studio and the guys that were here in
the room live we're criticizing Wesley's
next move
he moved his rook out of danger now it's
very common to sacrifice the exchange in
these positions and one of the players I
wish I can remember who it was said
woops sorry in this position if it was
White's turn to move they would consider
the mover up to c6 c6 is really where
the where the rook belongs but okay but
he saved material and Hikaru was
critical of this move to in the post
mortem and he he said some funny things
that Wesley wasn't he doesn't really
understand the Kings Indian he uses
computers and computers are you know
infamous for not understanding these
positions because of the horizon effect
they don't see how blacks attack is
going to crash through and how he's
going to sacrifice stuff and in the long
run it's going to work out for black so
not the best move by any means so he
saves his material and now alright
Bishop Bishop to h6 is he thinking about
some sacrifices okay so yes let's see I
don't really remember what happened here
so let's let's find out together
what should white do some would say rope
to c6 but he didn't play that Bishop to
e1 okay his Bishop is out of the way so
with black continues with g3 he doesn't
have to worry about the tempo on his
Bishop he can consider meeting g3 with
with h3 and then just you have to worry
for this big sacrifice but that's okay
it's nice to have the bishop out of the
way
occasionally this bishop will come over
here with some pressure so H for
threatening to play h3 and this is a
very typical pawn sacrifice in the
King's Indian that we should know about
he is of course offering this pawn and
perhaps it is a bit unwise to take it
but I don't know what else you know you
can play as white so okay I mean you can
play Bishop to b4 he took it yes and
okay and now things are about to get
really crazy and complicated I'll go to
the audience for a minute what do you
think black should play in this position
so already there's you know there's a
lot of stuff hanging in the air Hikaru
played a fantastic game I mean this was
one of the best games of the year was
definitely the best game of the
Sinquefield Cup in my opinion he played
f3 so wow he's a you know okay so the
Queen is now nice he's opening up this F
file as much as he can he's getting lots
of pressure he's not super interested in
winning the exchange hear that Bishop is
just too nice it's going to be a great
attacker
so now Wesley's going to take back and
now what's your what's your black play
things are about to get really crazy go
crazy it's okay you can be wrong because
they're not your pieces these are carros
pieces and it's great to see this kind
of chess at the top level um it's it's
not as as common you know anymore and
okay the Princeton boring tournaments
lately but this one was was fantastic so
and we got anything Knight takes e4 was
played fantastic yeah um and I do not
believe he took the knight okay so he
played rook to d1 if you take the knight
okay so you got to play rook to f1 and
you can't take the rook its untouchable
because checkmate yeah so there's really
crazy stuff that can can happen in this
position
so all right I set myself up for a hard
lecture because this game is gets even
crazier the ivory move was fantastic so
all right so you might want to pause
what should black do here whatever is
the craziest alright looks like we're
taking here you like taking there all
right excellent
so he took I doubt it was taken but
maybe it was no he took yeah I took the
bishop so this does allow rook to f1
which seems like the most logical
follow-up here
all right rook to f1 check again you
can't take it all right because if you
take it we got the same checkmate so
okay so he played King to g2
and now yeah again we have the same
appealing moves we can play rook Bishop
to e3
we can play h3 so put the move he played
looks pretty strong to the rook has come
into g1 and then okay that looks like
like a lot of trouble alright what can
white do how can we can we save this
position let's let's just look at this
for a second which I suppose wasn't
played yeah I wasn't played mm we'll
look at this see if we can figure out
what to do
and if you're just joining us this
opening was chosen at random so we
picked the most complicated thing
possible
yes a very very long night very long
night can't get enough okay how about
how about h3 here if you take I'm
bringing my queen in or I'm taking this
bishop something like this no give maybe
I got this move it's good yeah something
like that
so there's yeah truly fantastic stuff
going on here so you decided you can't
allow it and so he tried to sacrifice
his bishop somehow he's just got to get
these these rooks traded even if he
loses a little bit of material so he
takes the bishop and now he gets one of
the rooks off okay so all right let's
see we got lots of attacking moves here
Knight to g4 looks pretty good on the
King has to go to h3 so it's getting
very scary what should we do here let's
see what what should black play in this
position
yeah like Queen h6 and so did he
yeah ever threatened some some
discovered checks it's not super easy to
get out of them okay white chose to to
give away as pawn sometimes this King is
going to march up the board not the
safest but you got to do what you got to
do you're getting checkmated so you can
take the Jeep on with a knight and he
did and yeah when your kings marching up
the board like that and you're playing
Nakamura you're not going to win but
where where's the knockout here hmm
let's see what's the move okay so he
threatens Queen to h3 so we don't have
time to take this night because we're
getting checkmated oh yeah Queen h3 is
pretty strong how will he defend all
right Knight to f2 okay that defends the
square for now Knights not very safe on
f2 what should what should black play
here I think at some point he brings
this rook in but not not here check come
up the board
now the rook gets to come in with tempo
so he checks um and yeah this is a not
the safest King and I do remember this
move because this move was nice black
does have a forced win from this
position so who can figure it out and I
think there's several mates here but he
picked the coolest because he's a chess
artist you raise your hand real got six
and if I remember right that's what he
played and okay now he has Queen checks
they look pretty scary but where is the
mate who can find it somebody can find
it what can the guy in the back find it
what about the guys in the front black
smooth black smooth yep
yeah let's not forget - White has a
threat so everything's got to be Czech
Knight to e4 double check and alright
King only has one Square and where is
the checkmate we got we got one more
move and wisly allowed himself to be
checkmated over the board so you don't
get to see checkmates very often and you
don't get to see a king on g6 very often
so where is the checkmate in one move
everyone can find it even the people in
front yeah Queen g5 checkmate okay
fantastic yeah a truly wonderful game
and it's awesome to see such fighting
chess and it's you know awesome to be
here seeing this live and in person
in a car is one of those rare people
that does like to play some really
fighting aggressive stuff from time to
time and it seems like whenever he plays
Wesley so they get really exciting you
know games their game at the millionaire
chests open was also pretty exciting
from 2015 you might want to check that
out but yeah when they play it's
fantastic love watching them together so
we'll go back and now to be fair we'll
pick a game where white wins we'll go
back to our position after 91 and we'll
find a game for white the highest rated
game looks like we got Levon Aronian
versus Hikaru Nakamura and it looks like
Aronian was able to do what Wesley
couldn't so naka is going to lose this
game this was played in the World Team
Championship I'm assuming from 2010 it
looks like world team interesting
abbreviation okay so we'll see what as
blacks turns so we can expect the same
move Knight to d7 and what will Aronian
play will he do the same thing with f3
and maneuvering his Bishop to f2 or will
he go straight for Knight to d3
now after black plays f5 you're not in
time to play these moves because black
will immediately close the position so
it looks like he's going to do something
a little bit different let's let's see
so f5 was played and now Bishop to d2
and if I'm remembering right this is
also how the game between Elliot Leo and
Nick Carlo went and in that game this
when the pawn made its way to c5 he
jumped in with his Bishop and he jumped
in with his knight he didn't take on on
d6 right away he just created lots of
pressure on c7 so will they they be
following that game
let's see black it's his night back into
the game
c5 immediately rope to c1 or f3 okay he
supports his center and now okay black
has the same plans he's playing over
over on the Kings side
let's see c5 so c5 was played will he do
it will he do the Elliott Lee you plan
and gang up on the the c7 pawn so g5 and
he takes right away and all right we saw
what Wesley did he jumped right into to
c5 with his knight he might prepare it
so he's threatening to enter on the c7
square that we talked about okay and
this was one of the other points that I
mentioned the knight on d3 often goes to
f2 so looks like he's just defending
against the g4 break before it happens
whenever black is threatening to play
here he might have to play a move like
h3 but you know with the knight on f2
things are really a little safer it's
preventing the bishop sacrifice on h3 so
we'll see if any of that happens on this
game I am completely unfamiliar with so
maybe rook c1 all right Queen c2 and I
suppose one advantage of putting the
Queen on the C file rather than the rook
is now this other rook can come over
here and if necessary if you're getting
attacked on the King side perhaps the
the King can make a run in the other
direction so interesting and yeah also
in this position we are getting ready to
jump in with our Knight
so as usual black just defends in
anticipation of such a move so will we
see rook F 2 c1 yes alright so again
right so now we're ready and we got
three pieces that are going to be
on the square so black could defend the
square again which is what often happens
to that night and that's what we see so
excellent all right so if you jump in to
b5 right away probably you're not going
to go in here and after like a six your
night's going back and then blacks
attacking on the kingside so I assume
white made some very useful move on the
Queen side that I don't see what could
it be
all right I was right a four yeah so we
talked about this too in the other game
now if the knight ever makes it to b5
and they play a six we can retreat here
and come here without having to worry
about b5 shutting out or night
so yeah we talked about this last game
and now we see white trying in this one
so we'll we'll get to take a look at it
yeah here it comes when whenever he's
ready to play g4 looks like it's not
it's not quite ready yet why does too
many defenders
so maybe black's gonna have to at some
point put this rook here to get ready to
play the move like g4 all right should
you jump in with his knight
alright so he went back yeah the other
option was to go to b5 and then you know
maybe start getting some pressure here
on d6 but uh okay very interesting he
goes back to d1 and I guess he's saying
black has no attack and he's just going
to do things slowly on the Queen side
perhaps he can bring his other rook over
here and go really slow alright we're
going to see this is gonna be very
interesting
Bishop to f6 and yeah this is the usual
square for the bishop yeah and the other
game he ended up putting his Queen on f8
so okay B with Bishop on f8 and alright
rook to a3
yeah whites whites trying to triple here
so alright so was was white getting
ready to like put his bishop in here a
six so he could play rook to c3 or Queen
to c3 preparing to enter in some of
these these dark squares here on the
Queen side
and it's really to whites advantage to
trade the Queens because he's the one
that's getting checkmated but winning
positionally he wants to train as many
pieces as possible so blacks should do
his best to keep all the pieces on the
board and why it's going to be the one
trying to trade because in the long run
his advantage on the Queen side should
be able to win the day
alright Bishop to d7 so Queen a5 all
right so should black trade should he
move his queen
should he play the weakening b6 all
right b6 so white has provoked a
weakness and will notice the same square
as before so we saw Wesley put a rook on
c6 so that might be coming pretty soon
one of these rooks might go they're
preparing to even prepared to sacrifice
in exchange let's put the Queen back
let's go maybe to b4 so the queen is
still eyeballing some of these squares
making sure some of the black pieces are
tied down and black really doesn't have
an attack yet so okay
yeah the rook does come here he's really
trying to play the move g4 the white
gets a turn alright he could you know at
some point he could bring a rook in here
he could bring his other rook over first
he could play h3 if he thinks g4 is a
threat alright so he brings a rook in
and yeah so I'm thinking the rook is
coming to c6 with a similar pressure
that we saw in the other game all right
is g4 a threat it looks like it looks
like black might have just enough so h3
was played to prevent the move g4 okay
can black continue his attack can he
somehow get something going here will he
be able to get more pieces and play g4
and crush white okay rook c6 or bishop
e1 okay yes both players are going slow
this is a much slower maneuvering game
the other game action happened pretty
quick white made no progress on the
Queen side and black just attacked and
he
one brilliantly alright so let's see
Queen to be eight alright and blacks
Queen is stuck here Queen to be eight
whoops ah
the queen is kind of stuck defending the
beep on so maybe rip to see six
interesting so yeah he gets his king out
of the way because if ever G for happens
now his King is a little bit safer on
the F file so very slow maneuvering
nothing is you know truly exciting has
happened yet but it must be a common
okay so he got the Queen out of the way
so the bishop could come back now the
bishop defends the pawn okay and alright
so white attacks the weakness he attacks
b6 alright fantastic he can continue
attacking it with a move like work c6 in
the future and blacks really not playing
g4 here so white has has a lot of time
and all right we're moving all the
bishops around this guy has been on
quite the trip so far let's see so he
went here they went back will he
complete it will he go all the way we
will see all right Queen a3 yeah the
Queen goes back and yeah it's going to
be it's gonna be funny when the bishop
moves all right we got our rooks back
yeah
the bishop goes back and I did this
maneuver once in a game and it was it
was brilliant when I did it but it was a
much different position yeah if you can
shadow the bishop and then I I snaked
around and my bishop was awesome on a
seven so I like this maneuver because
I've seen it and I've done it ok
b4 okay looks like whatever he puts his
rook here on c6 if black ends up taking
it and he has a pawn here you might want
to solidify his past move on with a move
like b5 okay and you know okay maybe he
can think about tripling on the C file
getting Alekhine's gun I ripped to a7
defending the c7 square even more and on
a good day you know maybe he'll get
these rooks doubled over here and you'll
get to play g4 after all
Brooksie 6 we finally have it and I
doubt black took it even though yeah
Wesley was scared that Nakamura might
take the exchange but I yeah it wasn't
played so probably you take here we can
take back a couple ways but I like taken
with a pawn and black always has to
worry about us running really quick if
he you know at some point we might
solidify it with the move b5 so black
plays b5 himself now white won't play
that move alright and what can we do
well you should probably trade on b5
create a weakness
there's a bishop here so he trades now
we do have something looks like white is
doing really well on the Queen side his
queen is attacked at the moment so he
can move his Queen to b3 he can play
rook a6
he played rook a six and so this will be
interesting will black trade we know
black wants to keep as many pieces on
the board as possible so will he avoid
the trade will he play rook to b7 he
does okay let's see now we got another
rook that can come here
we got a knight that can jump into c3 we
got a lot of pressure here I'm with it
what will happen let's see
aha right he's insisting on sacrificing
in exchange and I assume black again
didn't take it but again black is not
getting his attack going and if if white
just gets to take these pawns he's going
to be pretty happy here he did take okay
so we should take back what would you
guys take back with a rook or a pond no
hide take back but how would you take
back you you
the rook terrible right awful yeah they
take you with a pawn that's a pretty
nice pawn you got here and it does give
me some squares like d5 you know maybe
my my knight will jump in here and
that's pretty good square for my knight
so yeah I only consider taking with a
pond how could you all right and so
black is willing to make a trade after
all I kind of like playing Knight to c3
which was played and then I can take
back with a knight if I wish interesting
very interesting
d5 so it does he have any tricks in mind
okay so a nice little trick so obviously
we can we can take the knight notice
that this is the point so he's not just
hanging a knight all right it looks like
we got this nice efore square for a
knight
oh yeah so I think g4 was an interesting
try he instead brought his rook over to
c7 he is attacking this this pawn a
little bit he's you know the C pawn is
pretty strong how come white maintain it
let's see what did he do interesting so
he took the Jeep on kind of risky now
the G file is opened so it'd be funny if
the rook came back and you know
checkmated white but alright but he's a
grandmaster so he takes pawns
alright Knight to g7 all right black is
going to go get this pawn here rook b6
Wow
fantastic stuff alright what's going on
did he blunder his Queen so let's see
did he did he take the Queen so he
didn't take the Queen Wow fantastic
fantastic let's check it out let's take
the Queen and see what happens
notice this Knight is doing a fantastic
job so we can take this bishop and the
King can't move so he's going to have to
defend looks like the only move is
Knight to e8 and then we can take it so
alright so far we have two pieces for
the Queen the King only has one move
farthest was easy to figure out all
right so I mean I have I have this move
and then check so we're where's your
king going to go
I assume you you have to go over here if
you get too close I'm thinking about
checking you away and and then okay
something like this looks really good
for white yeah it's just yeah this looks
like pretty crushing for white so I'd
expect you would have to go somewhere
else and now we can take your rook and
yeah you got a lot of material let's
grab this guy and you got yeah you got a
lot of quite a lot of material for the
okay yeah okay whoops not the best not
the best move I play oh this is typical
we get some some really exciting games
when you play the Kings Indian so truly
terrific he instead took on f5 which
does give up the bishop but I mean how
do you how do you even defend the bishop
very well in this position he decided to
sacrifice a piece so I would take the
bishop and he did and okay so the knight
is preventing the King from going to
most squares so his move was a bit
predictable
um all right how should we respond now
the queen is attacked so maybe we could
move our queen oops let's see what was
played all right Queen to be two he saw
that his Queen was attacked yeah at some
point blacks going to have it a good
check here on e3 I'm either immediately
he can maybe consider taking this how is
he going to respond here oh yes rook a
to as well yes the Brooks looks pretty
nice here what should we do about our
Queen Queen be one attacking a knight
yeah so even if you do check
which wasn't played even if you do check
me now you have to worry about my queen
coming in so I so you didn't go 493
instead played rook to c2 you know a
tricky move if we just take the rook
what is black playing here 93 Mario
Roper excellent yeah just fork in the
the pieces here
all right rook c2 the rook is
untouchable
so why probably didn't take it I could
try to get out of tricks by moving my
king I could maybe play rook to p7 also
rook takes b5 yeah so okay we got this
protected all right where will the Queen
go all right so the rook is still
untouchable for the the same trick hmm
in king g1 okay rook b7 kind of move I
was thinking about and king to h6
attacking the knight I mean there's a
it's a good square I want to move my
knight to anyway so the knight it's also
untouchable now we are threatening to
win this rook so if you take this we can
we can take this there's no more tricks
here
okay so Queen to c6 trying to make some
some tricks work here let's see all
right Knight to f7 my feeling is we're
going to have to take this Knight and he
took it
yeah and sexually it feels like you just
have to take that night white wins a
little bit of material alright let's see
and so there's like bishops hanging and
knights hanging the Knight has really
good square on e3 how should we proceed
as white things are pretty good for us
at some point we can push we can
well I was listen I move that Bishop
because we don't want to ruin this rook
to a7 with a threat
yeah cuz they so we're threatening work
to a6 which is pretty annoying at some
point you know I'm going to get my my
queen into the attack as well alright
let's see yeah so he's yeah Queen to a-1
he's just gonna get the Queen into the
game did he take the bishop and allow
Queen a 6e play something even crazier
he took on on g2 perhaps hoping for King
to g2 but your Queen a6 looks like it
just ends the game if you take on g2 now
you know you're allowing some
unnecessary counter play here though I
mean maybe you're fine I would just be
worried if there's potential for
perpetual checks but you know alright so
there's no really no reason to allow
that when you have an awesome move like
like we need a six which was played and
black gave it up yeah Queen to a6 is you
know is the death bell so alright so to
truly fantastic games the wrong once
again picked a fantastic opening it
seems to have a thing for sharp openings
and alright pretty late at night but
we're going to get this tournament
rolling let me know what you guys think
about the raagh I know it does sort of I
don't get to prepare as much so we do
sacrifice a bit of the quality of the
content but we do get to use a box which
is pretty cool so where do you fall are
you prologue are you anti rug let me
know I want to hear what you guys think
to see if we should ever do this again
in the future also special thanks to
Lulu ojek for coming up and helping me
create this box you did a fantastic job
and gets all the credit for it yes and
your comments your feedback like
subscribe hit all the buttons you can
and I'll see you guys next week
Oh